a person's strengths are often their  biggest weaknesses and so that also  means that their weaknesses can be their  strengths so me I am weak in all those  ways that I listed I am weak but I don't  accept that I don't accept that I am  what I am and that that is what I'm  doomed to be no I don't accept that I'm  fighting I'm always fighting I'm  struggling and I'm scrapping and I'm  kicking and clawing at those weaknesses  to change them  to stop them some days I win some days I  don't but each and every day I get back  up and I move forward with my fists  clenched toward the battle toward the  struggle and I fight with everything  I've got to overcome those weaknesses  and those shortfalls and those flaws as  I strive to be just a little bit better  today than I was yesterday